Рейси до Тегерана з Борисполя
скасовані на невизначений час.
Паніки в залі відльоту немає, але авіапасажири
пригнічені катастрофою літака МАУ в Ірані.
- Чув. Ми в шоці. Тим більше, родичі відлітають сьогодні.
- Чесно кажучи, добре, що я лечу не МАУ.
А взагалі дуже прикро, що відбуваються подібні катастрофи.
- Знову "Боїнг". Не можна дозволяти літати
сумнівним літакам, бо постійно повідомляється
про якісь технічні дефекти.
У МАУ повідомили, що рейс із Тегерана
до Борисполя виконувався літаком "Боїнг" 737
2016 року випуску. Авіакомпанія отримала його
безпосередньо з заводу концерну "Боїнг" і до цього
він  ніде не експлуатувався.
Останню технічну перевірку літак пройшов
буквально 6 січня, і жодних зауважень
на несправність авіасудна від екіпажу ні по прильоту
в Тегеран, ні безпосередньо перед вильотом не було.
Також у МАУ впевнені в високій професійності
пілотів та бортпровідників. На борту загинуло
9 членів екіпажу. Їхні родичі прибули до Києва,
аби чекати на рейс з тілами загиблих.
- Мій син - старший бортпровідник.
Зателефонувала донька зі Штатів о 6-й ранку, що
в Америці повідомили, що розбився літак МАУ.
Вона запитує, куди полетів Ігор. Ми кажемо:
в Тегеран, ранковим рейсом прилетить.
І потім по відео побачили падіння літака.
Уряд України створив кризовий центр, куди можуть
звертатися родичі загиблих.
Генеральна прокуратура України відкрила
кримінальне провадженням за фактом катастрофи.
Співробітники аеропорту кажуть, що вперше в житті
переживають таку масштабну катастрофу літака
української авіакомпанії.
- Їх то не повернеш. Дуже шкода.
Людини-то немає. Діток-то немає.
Серед пасажирів загиблого рейсу - дві громадянки України.
Найбільше серед загиблих громадян Ірану.
Також на борту були канадці, шведи, афганці, німці, британці.
Причини авіакатастрофи з'ясовуються.
Деякі авіаексперти назвали дивним збігом те, що
український літак зазнав катастрофи відразу
після ескалації конфлікту США та Ірану та обстрілу
американської військової бази.
Хоча версію збиття літака ракетою поки відкидають.
Тим не менше, деяким пасажирам у "Борисполі"
трагедія в Ірані нагадала збиття малайзійського
"Боїнга" МН17 в небі над Донбасом.
Дехто дивується, чому в Ірані не заборонили
польоти цивільних літаків на тлі
загострення ситуації.
- Коли йдеться про безпеку людей, треба якийсь
центр або процес координації, який би діяв у таких
критичних ситуаціях. Якщо десь виникає ескалація,
збройний конфлікт або ризики такі. Цей орган
має просто терміново включати якісь аварійні протоколи,
які будуть забороняти усім авіакомпаніям
польоти в цих регіонах.
- Я співробітник аеропорту.
Необхідно дочекатися розслідування.
Немає сенсу щось коментувати.
Треба знати реальну причину катастрофи.
Лише потім - усі висновки.
Такої ж думки дотримуються в МАУ.
Авіакомпанія не озвучуватиме жодних версій
причини авіакатастрофи літака до офіційних
висновків міжнародної слідчої комісії, яка буде
створена для розслідування трагедії.
Державіаслужба України заборонила польоти
в повітряному просторі Ірану всім українським авіакомпаніям
до з’ясування причин катастрофи.